author Mitchell nastas giving a talk at
the University of Kiel it's the 61st
stop on his book tour and around 800
people have come to hear him read from
his bestseller Jenna hot zone bit seems
unfazed about a commitment phobic
generation the book has topped the
German nonfiction charts for months in
anecdotes Nast writes about the
complicated love lives of singles
between the ages of 20 and 40 man finna
do not know and then you can recognize
yourself to degree in satires like this
vida as the state it really makes you
think Calvin ones I might at our age
whether you recognize yourself or not
you just can't escape it cuz it
surrounds you every day mattel Nast was
born in Berlin before he started writing
he worked in advertising in 2015 he
penned an online column describing the
commitment shy Generation Y the text
struck a chord and received over a
million clicks within a matter of days
the idea for the book was born listen
his authority I describe the
sensibilities of people considered
incapable of commitment by either
themselves or those around them there
appears to be a needful material like
this but within I don't pretend to be an
expert and a don't dispense advice I
take a literary of French Ablett to
create an authentic image of life nor
tenders as a Buddhist limsa for me
nast uses stories from his circle of
friends in Berlin to describe the
current attitude towards relationships
he tries to capture the love life of the
younger generation in sentences such as
we want to eternal devotion and
self-surrender but despair when we
realize that life rarely resembles the
movies Nast believes that young Germans
love lives have also changed because of
the proliferation of online dating sites
and dating apps they expand the pool of
potential partners and raise the bar the
problem is the problem is that
ultimately we've conformed so well to
our consumer society that we approach
interpersonal relationships like
consumers that the dating apps are a
good example they're set up like online
shops so we use the same principles to
go about choosing a partner as we do a
product in a partner verbal imported
coal Lisa Fishbach works as a couple
psychologist for elite partner one of
the largest online dating sites in
Germany it conducts studies into the
lives of singles including whether
they're incapable of committing emotions
Angus devanahalli the desire to have a
lifelong partner remains unchanged we
find that again and again in our surveys
ninety percent of people want someone to
be their one and only forever after
that's the romantic ideal but the
reality looks quite different as the
tolerance for frustration has fallen and
with it the staying power to suffer
through phases in which things aren't
going so well so the readiness to leave
a relationship has increased
relationships have grown more unstable
because there's less willingness to
invest in solving problems Fishbach says
the Millennials should really be
described as unwilling rather than
unable to commit and she thinks that's
due to their tireless quest for the
picture-perfect life
bazooka lachemann pass we're no longer
looking for a suitable partner to have a
happy relationship with instead we're
looking for the best partner for a
perfect relationship that means we're
also shoving the entire responsibility
onto the other party they must ensure
that the relationship works perfectly
social scientist christian smith says
the way in which the younger generation
conducts its relationships can be traced
back to the social changes of the last
40 years men no longer tend to be the
sole breadwinners with wives who are
economically dependent on them couples
split up more quickly but that doesn't
mean that love and relationships are a
thing of the past but ever since that's
what we're seeing is that the phases in
which people live alone are becoming
more frequent and these phases are
becoming increasingly socially
acceptable that's the biggest change but
I very much doubt that an entire
generation is incapable of forming
relationships I've back in kill even if
the experts don't think
commitment-phobic is the right way to
describe the love life of many young
Germans it makes for a catchy headline
doctor see the shared via people see
themselves in the book they identify
strongly with the material and
interestingly they use it as a means to
reflect upon themselves to get some
distance and look at life from a
different perspective and to look at
what isn't working out right so the
inverse fights life you could accuse
Mitchell Nast of generalizing the
experiences of young people living in
Berlin a very tiny sample of the
population but his books appeal is broad
it's already sold 140,000 copies across
Germany
you